I was in the library and this book was
on a stand I'd like to read you a page
my back over my hips as I asked if we
should take off take our clothes off and
he's saying yes before I finish my
sentence he's pulling off my t-shirt
laughing when I can't undo his shirt
buttons he's undoing my belt I'm
reaching into his bedside drawer for a
condom we're kissing again we're rolling
over obviously you can see where this is
going I don't know if it's because we're
feeling especially emotional or just
tired or these past couple of weeks have
been too much but this reminds me so
much of the first time we had sex we
were both [__] terrified and the
whole thing was kind of terrible because
we didn't know what we were doing look
at the moms but it was good too so good
because we were a mess of emotions and
we were scared and excited and
everything felt new so this sort of
thing this sort of feels like that Nick
touches me like he's scared at any
minute
now this book was at my middle school
and it was on a stand when I rented it
out to show my dad it uh the librarian
asked if I wanted more and if I wanted a
graphic novel version
[Applause]
I'm only shocked people are surprised
this is this is everywhere
okay good I was asking for you yeah I'll
take another three minutes so that's my
son okay 11 years old and went to his
library and found that
by the entry door
of our library this is the smut that he
is finding all right I don't care
whether it's gay straight bisexual
whatever the terms are for all this
stuff doesn't need to be at our school
doesn't need to be at my 11 year old's
library and then as far as genderqueer
I've got a son in the high school as
well and this is [__] We Know It All
right we do not need to be having
literature that's showing boys how to
suck dick all right this is a very very
frustrated about it okay and you may
think that schools know the best for our
children you know who know the best for
our children the parents
this is not an isolated example there's
thousands and thousands no no doubt
about this is why gays against groomers
are doing what they're doing we had them
on two weeks ago yeah so but but for me
you know how uh uh historically there
are some arguments that Republicans lost
where they lost 92 of the black vote
when they lost it Barry Goldwater you
look at how some arguments where you
know you lost the Hispanic vote because
hey they're for this this is the kind of
thing that could dramatically turn
parents against the Democratic vote
because it say somebody that just votes
just to vote and they don't think about
all the details that's going on but they
said wait a minute I'm voting for this
and that's what the Democrats support I
just don't support that so they may go
independent they may go I know earlier
today you were saying Joe manchin was on
uh a show where they were asking how are
you is there any chance that you could
run and he said hey you may run as an
independent yeah there's going to be
opportunities to look elsewhere because
the Democratic party argument
today is losing a lot of logical
arguments for parents
I completely agree
I think it's a opportunity for the uh
for the other side to make the
presentation to connect with the parents
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]